hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled new challenges for sars
cov2 diagnostics
viral load testing and variant strain
genotyping
this webinar is part of the corona virus
virtual event
series and i'm susie valdez of
labyrinths and i will be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar
is presented by lab route and sponsored
by lgc sarah care
for more information about lgc serocare
go to sarahcare.com
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the q and a box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
simply click on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
as a reminder this presentation is
educational
and offers free education credits click
on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right hand corner
of your presentation window and follow
the process to obtain
those credits i now want to introduce
our presenters today
dr russell garlick chief scientific
officer at lgc clinical diagnostics
and dr nathan ledeboer professor and
vice
chair of pathology and medical director
at medical college at wisconsin
for a complete biography of our speakers
please please visit the biography
tab at the right of your screen
gentlemen welcome to both of you you may
now begin
your presentations
well thank you very much for the kind
introduction today and thank you for
joining us
on this webinar exploring testing
options and exploring some of the
limitations and benefits
of testing in the sars cov2 pandemic
this webinar will focus on viral load
testing
and the potential utility of viral load
testing as well as identification of
variant strains and genotyping
my name is nate ludwar i'm a i'm a
professor in the department of pathology
at the medical college of wisconsin and
i also serve as medical director of the
microbiology
and molecular diagnostic sections for
wisconsin diagnostic laboratories and
freighter health
as we start to think about the sarge
kov2 to pandemic and as we start to
think about
the potential role of viral load testing
there are a number of important
considerations that we need to think
about and that we need to consider
and one of the biggest challenges that
laboratories
have encountered throughout the pandemic
is getting
access to testing and then really
addressing the question of
what is the best test for detection of
the sars cov2 virus
well we're not going to tackle that
question today
it's important to recognize that there
are a number of different assays
that are available for the detection of
sars cov2
the mainstay of testing has largely been
pcr
or nucleic acid amplification testing
it's the gold standard
it's the most sensitive method it offers
a great deal of variation
on the specimen types that we can work
with
including nasopharyngeal specimens
oropharyngeal specimens
nasal swabs saliva and even stool
but the challenge with pcr in most cases
is that it's lab based we need lab
experts to run the test
and they've been very few options for
point-of-care testing or testing
for laboratories that don't have big
large
instruments to handle high volumes it's
also important to recognize
that while pcr is the most sensitive
methodology
tends to also be the most expensive
a number of other methods have been
developed these include
a resurgence of antigen testing while
antigen testing has been reported to
have variable levels of sensitivity
for symptomatic patients most studies
have now concluded
that antigen testing is between 80 and
85 sensitive
compared to pcr antigen testing has the
benefit
of being very amenable to the point of
care and can be either read
visually or via an instrument
we've also seen the application of
antibody testing
to the detection of the sarsko v2 virus
and this has proven to be very useful in
assessing
the rates of infection in individual
populations
in understanding disease prevalence in a
population
and more recently in assessing vaccine
exposure
in individual patients so while these
are
all important diagnostic modalities
for the detection of sars kobe 2 for the
purposes of our discussion today
we're largely going to focus on the
application of pcr
and if we look to the idsa for their
recommendations
on where we should use pcr they
recommend the
use of pcr or nat testing in symptomatic
individuals suspected of having coping
they also recommend its application to a
number of asymptomatic
individuals including those with known
or suspected infection
including those patients where the
results of the test
will impact isolation quarantine or
personal protective equipment
as well as asymptomatic individuals or
results can dictate your eligibility for
a surgical procedure
or can inform administration of an
immunosuppressive therapy
so even the idsa recognizes just how
important
pcr is for the detection of the sars
code v2 virus
now one of the things that many
laboratories have encountered throughout
the pandemic
is the need to be able to provide very
very large volumes of testing
our laboratory for example went from
performing about a hundred
respiratory tests per day prior to the
pandemic
to at its peak performing more than 8
000 tests per day
this put a huge strain on the supply of
available testing reagents
and it meant that laboratories needed to
implement
multiple methods in order to address
the needed volume this meant in many
laboratories
that they weren't doing one pcr or two
pcr methods
but they may have been doing as many as
eight different
pcr methodologies and when we come to
doing
five six seven eight pcr methods
we have to recognize that there is a
great
deal of variation across individual
tests
based upon the manufacturer and the
limit of detection of those tests
and this was nicely summarized in on the
fda website
in an evaluation of the limits of
detection
of available eua approved assays
so in this study the fda's center for
diagnostics
and radiation health sent out a sarscovi
reference panel
to manufacturers with an eua cleared
test
the panel had four unknowns and one
heat inactivated strain of the sarco v2
virus
which was diluted to a reference
standard of 1.8
times 10 to the eighth units per ml
the fda then assessed the limits of
detection
across each manufacturer's tests
based upon this panel and they found
significant levels of variation across
each manufacturer
with the limits of detection ranging
from 180
to 600 000 in
new data units or ndus per mil
there were approximately 10 tests with
the limit of detection
below 1000 ndus per ml
an additional 26 tests with an lod
between
5 000 and 10 000 ndus per ml
and there were more than 10 tests with a
limit of detection
of 180 000 ndus per ml
or greater now while the individual
numbers don't matter
it is important to matter or it is
important to recognize
that the variation of in lod
across each of these manufacturer's
tests
ranged between 1 000 and 180
000 or more than two logs
and that's important as we start to
think about
asking questions around quantitation
it's important we understand
our deaths it's important we understand
how low they go
and it's important to understand how
reproducible they are
so why do we care about quantitation why
is it of interest
and what is quantitation we all know
that we've been doing
quantitation of nucleic acid inpatient
specimens
for decades it's a mainstay of managing
hiv patients
we routinely use it in the management of
cancer patients
we routinely use it in managing
immunosuppression of patients and
looking at viral loads
but it really begins with the ct value
or the cycle threshold value
and for the purposes of our discussion
today the ct value
is defined as the point in which our
real-time pcr
curve becomes logarithmic or as you can
see on the top graphic
where the line becomes straight
if we use a standard curve of known
quantitative standards we can begin
to assess the amount of virus that may
be present in a patient's specimen
so to establish our standard curve we
take known standards
beginning with a low quantity of virus
and ending with a high quantity of virus
and we run individual pcrs on those
standards
you can see in this top graphic the
lowest standard tends to be on the right
hand side
has a ct value of 30 and the
standard that contains the largest in
monovirus has a ct value of
approximately 12.
we then plot those ct values
on and as you can see that on the graph
on the bottom
against the known quantity of virus
and you can see we have a very nice
linear line we then go back to eighth
grade algebra
and we use the old equation of y equals
mx plus b
to determine the viral load by solving
for x
y equals the ct value we know the ct
value from our pcr test
we input that ct value into our equation
m and b are standard from our best fit
line
and we solve for x and then solving for
x
it helps us to determine the viral load
of that individual patient
again these are things we've been doing
for decades
when we manage immunosuppression when we
manage transplant associated infections
when we manage hiv we're now beginning
to ask the question
is this of significance as we apply it
to the sars kobe 2 pandemic
and some studies would say absolutely
it's of significance
and this is a study published by magleby
and colleagues
in clinical infectious diseases and in
this study
the authors suggest that patients with a
higher viral load
or lower ct value were more often
at risk of death as opposed to patients
with a lower or with a higher ct or
lower viral load
so as you can see from this graphic
patients with
low cts indicating high viral loads
had upwards of a 50 chance of dying
versus patients with a lower ct
or with am sorry a higher ct or lower
viral load
had a lower chance of dying
so it's studies like this that really
push us
to ask the question can we
use real-time pcr data
in order to report viral loads and is
that of
significance well there are a number of
important considerations
that we need to think about when
potentially reporting
quantitative values for respiratory
viruses
and this really begins at the time of
specimen collection
the easy thing of doing viral load
testing for example
in blood is that blood is fairly
homogenous
the presence of the virus no matter what
portion you sample
what vein you sample is likely to be
very similar
when we think about respiratory viruses
variation in collection technique can
significantly alter the amount of virus
that you detect
for example if we collect a nasal swab
as opposed to an np swab we may get
different levels of virus in the nasal
swab versus the np swab
the amount of that i scratch against the
nose or the amount of pressure that i
apply to the swap
may result in different quantities of
virus that may be released
we've gone to and utilized different
suppliers for transport media
we've looked at using saline for
transport of specimens
transport media can have a significant
impact
on pcr efficiency and the amount of
virus that we detect
the amount of transport media that's
included in our vial
can have an impact on viral load the
amount of time that it takes
to get to the laboratory and if that
specimen was maintained properly
can have a big impact on viral load
what i'm getting at is that in many
cases the collection
and detection of respiratory viruses has
largely been designed
around the concept that these are
qualitative assays
they're designed for reliable detection
of an individual pathogen
and they are not necessarily designed
for reliable quantitation
when we think about moving from
qualitative to quantitative
we really need to start to think about
including reference standards
this ensures reproducibility it helps us
to ensure precision of our assay
it also helps us to look at variation
in viral load or variation in ct between
methods between manufacturers tests
and across multiple lots of tests it
helps us to ensure that
our targets quantitate similarly
because we know that there can be
different amounts of e-gene
as compared to nucleocapsid for example
and we also know that extraction
platform can account for significant
levels of variability
and this was all nicely highlighted in a
study published by dan rhodes and
colleagues
as a part of a statement from the
college of american pathologist
microbiology resource committee
and in this particular study they looked
at ct values
for gene targets and manufacturers
across the same batch of testing
material so we all know how cap
proficiency testing works
we get unknown samples we test it like
we do a clinical sample
and we report results back to the cip
we report that in addition to the method
that we report
and you can see that at the time that
this data was collected
the largest platforms included the bd
max platform
the cdc test the gene expert
the 6800 as well as a host of other
different instruments
and each of these tests utilize
different genes
and while we saw a relative scattering
of ct values all around the 30 range
we saw significant variation across
manufacturers tests
so for example it with the cdc assay
across 67 laboratories that were
performing the cdc method for detection
of the sarsko b2 test
some reported ct values as low as 28
while others reported ct values as high
as 41.
for the thermal fissure method the
average ct was approximately 31
with some laboratories reporting ct
values as high as 35
and others reporting them as low as 25.
a variation of 10 cts is quite
significant and can represent
more than a log difference in viral load
so understanding how reproducible our
tests are
understanding what our tests quantitate
and
how our test quantity are really crucial
to begin to assess whether there's any
utility to reporting viral loads
we also need to think about the
frequency and the need
for controls because it changes
significantly
based upon a quantitative test as
opposed to a qualitative test
for quantitative tests we need to make
sure that we verify the limit
of detection and really know just like
the lady here doing
the limbo underneath her car we need to
know how low our test goes
we need to understand how frequency we
run controls at minimum we need to do a
positive
and a negative control for each run for
quantitative tests
we also need to be running calibrators
to ensure
that we get reproducible quantitation
so we partnered together with six other
medical centers
to begin to look at can we accurately
quantify virus and can we develop
controls
to be able to help in assisting
quantitation of the virus
so this really began to ask the question
can we move from
semi-quantitative rt-pcr by
quote-unquote reporting the ct values
can we generate a standard curve can we
report in copies per ml
and is that reproducible across multiple
laboratories
and across multiple platforms
to do this we developed a series of
calibrators
which range from 300 to 1 million copies
per mil
and we assess the linearity of a panel
using both
real-time pcr and digital pcr
and we did this across seven labs with
geographical diversity
in the united states so the first thing
that you need to do when we develop a
panel of calibrators
is really to determine can we build a
number of different targets and
accurately measure those targets
using both digital pcr and real-time pcr
and you can see from this graphic the
panel that we built began at 300
copies per mil and ended at 1 million
copies per ml
and what we measured was actually quite
similar or we had a target of 316 on the
lower end
we detected 393. or we had a target of 1
million on the upper end
we detected 1.1 million so we had a
pretty
linear panel that we were able to
develop
so once we've established an appropriate
reference panel
that is linear across the range that we
wanted to test
the next question really comes down to
is this panel reproducible
across multiple laboratories and is it
reproducible across
multiple platforms so we recruited seven
sites running multiple different test
methods
in order to assess this question these
sites included
uh these sites included laboratories
running the abbott alinity
the avid m2000 the cdc method
the roche 6800 test the cepheid gene
expert
the chiastat as well as a site running
in ldt
using cerbeco reagents
we then asked each site to perform the
panel
repeat the panel to run the panel and
report
ct values back to
the central collection site what we
found was
that across individual platforms the
panel was very linear
so the panel did what it's supposed to
do and it found
high viral specimens and adequately
distinguish those from low viral
load specimens we also found
that when run on a single platform the
results were quite reproducible
so look for example to the lower set of
lines
on the graph you'll see three individual
sites
ran the m2000 asset and regardless of
the site performing the test
the ct value that was reported for each
known standard was very very similar
now quite interestingly we also did
notice that the m2000 ended
uh ended up reporting ct values that
were a bit
lower than the other platforms and this
is largely because
it runs its first 10 cycles of pcr
in a silent motor in a blacked out mode
where the labs don't see the results and
it only begins to report
ct values at that after that 10 cycles
of report
so if we correct for that on the
abandonm 2000 platform
and we normalize across all of our
individual sites
you'll see that the overall ct values
that were reported across our sites
were reasonably reproducible and they
generally fell within a range of about
five
cts if we then translate that
into viral load detection
the data becomes even more interesting
so for the viral load detection
we had four laboratories run let's run
the tests
the calibrators were run across two
digital pcr platforms
as well as on the m2000 and the cerbeco
qpcrs
and again if we look at viral load
detection
you actually find that regardless of the
method
that the test is run on the individual
laboratories report viral loads that are
very very similar to each other
and are within the expected level of
variation
across the laboratories so we certainly
were able to at least early on
demonstrate
that when we include the proper controls
when we include the proper calibrators
and if we can standardize for all of
those other things that we talked about
viral load testing is a possibility
should the field continue to move
towards
needing viral loads reported on
individual patient results
i'll thank you for your attention today
and i'll look forward to hearing
russell's portion of the talk so i'll
hand things now
back to russell thank you nate for that
terrific presentation
now i will speak on the emergence of
cyrus kobe 2 mutations in genotyping
i'll speak about the mutations in the
background
talk about assays and of course
reference materials for assay
development
validation and qc and then both nate and
i will be available for a q a session
so science kobe 2 mutations
let me first start with a discussion on
nomenclature
it can be very confusing so i think we
should be all on the same page as far as
how we're using the terms mutation
variance and strains
a mutation is it refers to an actual
amino acid change in the sequence
case example is d614g which is
a switch of aspartic acid to a glycine
substitution at position 614 of the
spike glycoprotein
a variant is a change in the genomic
sequence
and in the case of d614g it's actually a
nucleotide
change at the genomic position 23403
again in spite protein the strain
is a variant or a collection of variants
that demonstrate
a different phenotype could be
antigenicity transmissibility infection
virulence or escape from various
therapeutic agents especially monoclonal
antibodies
examples are b117 and 501v2
and b1128 we'll get into more details of
this
as we go through the presentation all of
these different strains include
one of the mutations d614g plus many
other mutations
and very importantly for today's
discussion how it impacts laboratories
what does the cdc say about these
classification of variants
variants can be of interest at vois
these where mutations can span multiple
genes and regions
they're being watched for a concern
in potentially high consequence so a
variant of concern
is a variant that could induce a change
in nitrogenicity transmissibility
variance any of these could potentially
become
a variant of high consequences the vocs
are being very watched closely
and all the ones we're following today
are actually in the sg
experience of high consequence can lead
to
a failure of diagnostics that is the
assay doesn't detect them
can cause a significant reduction in
vaccine effectiveness
it could be causing high breakthrough in
vaccine
administrations who could have low
vaccine-induced protection against
severe disease
significantly reduced susceptibility to
to multiple
emergencies authorized repeat
therapeutics
more can cause more severe disease or
increased toxicity
so these are really key uh consequences
of these mutations in the syscov2 virus
fortunately today none have been
classified as
vohc or variance of high consequence
i like this website because this gives
you a a
really well researched and referenced
report on each of these variants this is
the
covariance.org website and as an example
i'm showing you
the variant e484 as you go to this
website
you'll see all the recent publications
of importance to talk about
changes in in vitro
characterization of this particular
strain
and it can cause in this first one here
this mutation may may
significantly reduce convalescence
hearing neutralization with a nice
reference
so i'd really highlight this website as
a place to go to learn more about
a specific variant
now where are we today in the united
states this is rapidly changing
this is from the cdc website and it
shows
the percent of the total viruses
done identified by ngs sequency across
the united states
and as you can see between january of
this year 2021 in mid-march of this year
the original wuhan strain of b1
b point 1 2 you can see is actually
declining
in prevalence within the u.s population
and
other variants are actually increasing
the b117 which is originally isolated in
the uk
as you can see it's dramatically
increasing over time
if you look at the current data in my
home state of massachusetts
b117 is about 50 percent of the cases
right now
now this table shows the different
variants classified in the percent
identified across the u.s
it also shows whether it's a variant of
concern or a variant of interest
here is the b12 the original wuhan
these are the two california uh
variants b1427 and b1429
as well as you can see down you know p1
is actually growing a severe
another variant of concern down here at
the lowercase
so this particular cdc website shows the
cumulative across the us i would highly
recommend for any of the laboratories
you know keep a close eye
on your regional variants that are
circulating in your
area as well
so some more background information on
cytoscopy two
mutations you know viruses are mutating
all the time we know that and it's been
going on
uh for over a year right now we don't
continue to go some of these variants
become
dominant due to selective advantage of
the virus whether that's binding to the
h2 receptor
there are multiple approaches to assess
these mutations whether they're bois
vocs or bohcs
for the most part they're in vitro
detection methods right now
the us has created this sars
inter-agency group
called sig which is now integrating data
and activities between these major
organizations within the us to
focus on these variants of concern and
really
dive into data sharing and make sure
we're starting to get ahead
of the impact of these variants on
therapies and diagnostics
the fda has reported that
for in silicon analysis if it predicts a
performance change of greater than five
percent
then the laboratory should use that
assay and test with clinical samples
or use synthetic rna that includes these
representative mutations to determine
how it impacts
the assay and notification is required
to the fda
if there's a performance change for
example
a change of 3x increase the limits of
detection
also on b1315351 it shows a six
times lower neutralization than the
wuhan strain
and this is important because these are
this data that you'll be seeing it this
is only neutralization tighter but it
doesn't really reflect the immunological
status of the patient it doesn't
respond reflect what the memory b cells
or the t
cell activities are invoking for
immunity
but e484k is considered an escape
mutation for therapeutic
antibodies i'll say a little bit about
that in a minute so
let's let's be very aware from a
laboratory perspective
um we should be looking very carefully
at our assays
um and be testing our assays uh with
synthetic rna
or i will show you in in the subsequent
slides here how you can use the accuplex
technology
to test if your assay can detect these
various variants
this chart shows the structure of the
binding
of the saskov2 spike receptor binding
domain
protein directly to the ace2 receptor
the virus uses the ac2 receptor to gain
entry into the cell
for reproduction and we have so much
knowledge now about the exact
binding of the virus to the structural
proteins
and as more information is being
generated in this case it's a
bioinformatics approach
looking at the binding of the spike
protein to the h2 receptor
and the potential changes that you can
have with these mutations
so here's the wuhan strain of the
suscrobi 2 binding to the ace receptor
and here's the e484 site
that amino acid site and over here in
this particular part of the section
shows where
e484 is is mutated to a lysine group
and that impacts it actually makes the
binding a little bit stronger
uh showing more infectivity of this
particular
strain to the h2 receptor and causing
greater infection
in the population so we know a lot about
the particular mutations that impact not
only on the assays potentially on the
assays
but also on the therapeutics that are
being in development
the fda is also providing alerts for
variants
as they impact monoclonal therapy
this is a very successful drug for lily
it's called bam
land nimab and it was introduced as a
monotherapy
for uh covert 19 patients who are
mild to moderate with the potentially
with with
multiple cofactors and
the uh the data shown in this alert is
pseudovirus neutralization data for sas
copy 2 in the variants and substitutions
so on this um a column here at the
different
lineages from the 117 south african
brazil et cetera california
and the key substitutions that were
tested
as you can see no change with the uk
117 but significant change in the
pseudo-virus neutralization data
for these various strains and
consequently the fda has provided alert
not to use this this drug as a model
therapy
but fortunately it can be used very
successfully
with a combination of other monoclonal
therapies on
especially the bam libid
with other monoclonal antibodies so a
very
proactive approach by the fda providing
these alerts
and what's important for us laboratories
is to make sure that
we're very much aware of what the fda is
saying as far as neutralization
to other monoclonals that could be on
the marketplace
so not only have to pay attention what
the fda is saying
regarding the laboratory tests but also
the impacts on therapeutics and
potentially on vaccines as well
now considerations for the laboratory
this is an excellent publication
from filkins sorel
scogens in jason park the university of
texas
published in clinical chemistry and it's
targeted to
laboratories and manufacturers about
revalidating their assays to confirm
limits of detection
with the emergence of virus variants in
our
regional areas now quote from the paper
genetic changes may not cause a total
loss in signal
but may lead to a decrease or increase
detection efficiency
efficiency therefore laboratories should
consider confirming acid limited
detection when the new variant becomes
prevalent within the population tested
or quantitative reference materials
become available to determine the
analytical sensitivity so
laboratories have to be very proactive
whether it's a
an ivd assay or an ldt assay
the authors point out that ibd
manufacturers actually do not
test for mutations with real samples or
standards but really relying on silicon
analysis
it's up to the laboratory to take the
lead and do these testings
and case in point the b117
impacted both the tacpath thermoassay
and the linnea
applied dna sciences pcr assays and
there were s
dropouts since these assays look at
three different regions just having an
acid dropout
didn't impact the positive or negative
call for these particular tests
but it was the original identification
of how these variants were impacting
the assay so a very good reference
to look up is this clinical chemistry by
the park laboratory
now let's move on to assays so with
cytoscopy 2
genotyping let me just provide an update
today there are no
emergency use authorized genotyping
assays using either rt pcr
or sequencing there are assays from
these particular companies that have uas
using ngs but they're qualitative assays
they're not screening they're not
genotyping
it's a yes no is a person infected or
not
ngs has a number of approaches um used
for screening to identify these variants
for example thermo just launched a 22
variant panel
which is our uo label uses rtqpcr and
attackpath assay
and runs on an abi pcr instrument and
uses the quant studio reado
so here's one of the first iuo assays
that
you can actually adapt to identify these
variants
again it's for genotyping there are many
laboratory
developed tests using rtq pcr they're
targeting some of these vocs and vo
merging vohcs as well predominantly de
novo sequencing is used
today either on the illumina playoff
platform
with the mysq instrument or the next
seat using the arctic
protocol or the oxford nine poor using
the lampport high throughput cover 19
assay so
a couple of different ways to look at
really getting a
a deep view into the variants within
your regions
this is a snapshot from
biosearch lgc biosearch one of my
colleagues
companies and this shows the
specifications and comparison of probe
based rtpcr
versus whole genome sequencing i'll just
point out a couple points here
so you can go to this website and get
lots of information about the
primer probe materials that are
available from biosearch
but the variance detected in the probe
is just you have to design the assays
for what you're looking for
with whole genome sequencing you see
them all
design requirements uh every variant has
a new
new design this is an unrequired since
whole genome sequencing
this is fast sequencing slower
this is a standard well accepted
methodology
greater expertise required here a little
bit higher cost than sequencing
right now will be high throughput on the
genotyping assays and lower throughput
on sequencing assays but as we advance
our variant testing i think you'll see
more
sequencing based approaches get to high
throughput and at lower cost as we
continue to
see the importance for detecting
variance in the population
now let me move to reference materials
and the role here for
lgc's eric here
we've been using the
acuplex technology since the beginning
of the pandemic to produce
recombinant cysco p2 virus
that can be used for acid development
acid validation and qc
and very briefly what we do is we take
the sequence of interest whether it's
the original wohan or
these variants that we've been talking
about we call them
and the into in the rna is introduced
into a million cell culture for
production
uh this is industrialized at scale so we
can make
lots of materials for many different
laboratories and companies
the symbis virus that
that is used to produce the
sequence is actually produced in the
cells
and is a fully encapsulated virus so it
has to go through a full extraction
um in these virus particles are
replication deficient
but we also go through a heat treatment
step to ensure
you know kind of a a double a safety
approach that
they're non-infectious and what we've
been able to do is now we have the full
genome size kobe 2
with the war on lineage and what we've
done now is we've added
new sequences that are applying that are
applied to these variants of interest
let me show you that next so for example
this is the region within the
s gene despite protein this particular
strain we've actually included all of
these different variants
in the mix so that there's two
deletions and a number of these
mutations here
shown by the letter changes this is all
within the s g
and so the sg variants from the b17 we
actually spike it into
the original wuhan h201
to get the full genome for this
particular
accuplex construct
and this table shows the different amino
acids
the nucleotide changes in three
different constructs that we have on our
first product again this is the accuplex
of full process reference material
um construct one has all of these x's of
the mutations that are included
uh construct two is the south african
and
and con struck three is the brazil japan
you can see the x's mean all those
mutations are included
so now you have a choice of using um
detecting each any of these constructs
these mutations across the estrine with
a different two
and i've just highlighted in yellow here
two of the
mutations i've talked about throughout
the
presentation e484k which you can see is
in these two constructs and the d614g
which is actually in all three of these
constructs d614g
seems to have higher infectivity in some
in vitro assays
so this is the size kobe 2
accuplex constructs that we have
now we have actually have two product
formats
uh the first product format is the
accuplex which we just talked about
and we have the positive reference
material so we have these three
constructs plus the wuhan the original
uh wohan genome uh it's 1.5 mils
about 5 000 copies per mil in the
universal transport meeting and we also
include a
negative reference material which is the
human rna sp
this is our uo labeled and for
sequencing we've
developed the cyber size kobe 2 rna
mix what's different here is that in the
single two we have 80 variants across
the whole genome so there's 38 mutations
in the s gene
16 mutations in orbit 1a and f1b
26 and 3a e
m etcetera as you can see so again this
is now designed
for mgs applications and particularly
important we'll be determining the
limits of detection for these assays
so we're actually making rna mixes at
these little fractions one percent
five percent 20 so you can start testing
the lods for your assays concentration
again five million copies per ml
you can see the uh nanograms per ml here
in
a background of gm243a5 celine extracted
rna and qc released
qubit digital to determine copies per ml
and then we use ngs to confirm the
variance
so both of these products are just in r
d right now please contact
contact us at lgc ceracare
for more information about these
products
so now i'd like to uh welcome nate
back to the webinar and we can do a a q
a
again thank you very much for attendance
and i look forward to some questions
and i want to thank you dr garlick and
dr letterboard for that informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a
portion of the webinar if you have any
questions you want to ask please do so
now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen so let's get started
it looks like we already have some great
questions coming in from our audience
members
now are there any current mutations or
strains
in particular that you were concerned
about
i will let russell answer that one has
he connected back into us
[Music]
and i think we're just waiting for him
to reconnect
how about if i go ahead and ask another
question
um are the ocuplex rep materials
or purified rna for genotyping or
sequencing to be used differently or are
they interchangeable
that's going to be another russell
question um
so i think we'll wait until he comes
back on that one as well
okay um let's see here let me
let me move on to another question and i
want to thank our audience
question for their awesome questions
coming in already
um who says
that sars kobe 2 can be isolated from
blood as you mentioned the various
specimen
limitations for quantitative respiratory
viruses
is there any possibility of seeing
blood-based
quantitative tests in the future
so this is a great question um and
there's been a number of investigations
into using
not only blood but a number of other
specimen types
to improve the diagnosis for sarge kov2
we've seen data on blood we've seen data
on stools
quite interestingly the data on stools
is very very
good showing reasonably high sensitivity
there
um blood it ultimately depends upon the
assay we're seeing
variable levels of sensitivity um and
variable levels of shedding
of the cyrus kobe 2 virus within the
serum so i think we would
certainly need some additional data and
some additional study really following
the kinetics of viral circulation in the
blood before we
uh move forward entirely with that um
because i do think we would want to see
some additional data around
serum plasma the duration of how long
those patients would be viremic
the level of viremia and truly whether
that's associated
better or worse with progression of
disease in individual patients so
we've seen data that shows that it can
be detected in serum
we really need to see some of that
additional data of how well does that
correlate with clinical disease
as well as how does it perform across
multiple different
assay platforms what a great question
thank you so much dr letterboard and
we'll continue to wait for dr garlick
reconnecting now you cite the article
that recommends
checking lods when a new variant becomes
prevalent
in local populations in practice what
does that mean
dr letterboard so generally it can mean
a couple of different things
so the first thing that you can
generally do is if you're using it will
differ if you're building your own test
versus
if you're working together with a
commercial manufacturer of your test
if you're building your own test you
really need to be on a fairly regular
basis
taking your primer probes searching them
against
all of the known sequences and really
making sure that those primer probes
will amplify
across the new the new variant sequences
as well
it's also an important reason why when
we develop tests
for the stars cov2 virus we don't target
just a single gene
so we see many diagnostic tests that
will have
targets against the e genes targets
against
the spike protein or the spike protein
gene targets against the nucleocapsid
gene
and by using a multi-targeted approach
that
really improves the chances of us
finding it and
decreases the chances of a single snip
or a single variant
ultimately having a major impact
on resulting uh or providing accurate
results
now if you're working together with a
commercial partner
for your assay you can the easiest way
to do this really is in partnership with
your commercial partner they are
required
to on a routine basis perform
surveillance make sure that their assays
are detecting variants and notifying
customers
so the easiest way to do it with a
commercial vendor is really
working together with that vendor and
partnering with them to make sure that
they're doing that in a timely manner
and that they're giving you
documentation
to be able to prove that information
thank you so much
and dr garlick welcome i'll give you
this next question dr garlic
are there any current mutations or
strains in particular that you are
concerned about
yeah great question um so again for my
local massachusetts uh data that's being
generated
um p1 has already been introduced into
the population
so it's more infectious and perhaps has
more disease outcome
so that's being closely watched as well
as the
the b1351 that originated in south
africa so
even within you know massachusetts lots
of travel going back and forth those two
uh are variants of concern that are
being followed very closely
thank you so much and dr garlic are the
accuplex
ref materials or purified rna
for genotyping or sequencing to be used
differently or are they
interchangeable so the way i like to
look at this is the purified rna
is very good in the initial stages of
assay development and validation
and it's it you can use it to to
standardize optimize the reverse
transcriptase step
and as well as the pcr step very good
for that you can prove you can detect
these variants
it's a good positive control for that
aspects but as nate mentioned during his
presentation we're generally dealing
with respiratory
viruses and it's the whole workflow that
you have to really think about
the performance and precision
reproducibility
in the acuplex material since it is a
full process control
it's encapsulated virus it's in
universal transport meter
it's actually a better reference
material to really monitor
the assay over time and to prove for
your laboratory and as you report out
results
that your assay is performing
appropriately so they have different
utility um but they're both very
valuable tools
for the laboratories thank you so much
and again i want to thank our audience
for their participation these are great
questions
coming in gentlemen there are calls for
investing
in high throughput testing example
greater than
fifty thousand to a hundred thousand
tests per day
at the regional or state level to
address the issues
of test capacity that we've encountered
a year ago
what is the role of medical center
testing and local public health labs
supporting high throughput testing
so susie this is a this is a great
question i think this really
goes to what can we learn from the
result or what can we learn as a result
of this pandemic
and how do we make sure that we are
adequately prepared for the next
pandemic
um because certainly one of the biggest
issues that we've experienced
early on and thankfully this has
somewhat subsided since then
is test availability and test capacity
and what we are largely going to see is
we're going to need to see partnerships
that are developed
that include the local medical centers
the national reference laboratories
as well as local and regional public
health laboratory
really partnering together to build this
level of capacity
within within our health care system
one of the key things that we really
learned early on was we relied on too
few laboratories to ultimately do much
of the early testing
quite interestingly if i look back a
year from now
we were you know just we had been
testing for about a month
but when we started to build our assay
and we really started to look at
how do we how are we going to address
this pandemic
we were told by the fda no you can't
perform testing
because you haven't submitted anything
yet in terms of your clinical trial
and you can't submit any data on
performance of your assay
until you've had a case and
that was that was incredibly frustrating
not only for our lab but for many others
and
so we you know i think moving forward we
need to remove some of those regulatory
barriers
and also find ways that we can push
that testing down into the clinical labs
into the reference labs
and support it through public health to
make sure that we can address this
moving forward so
a lot of it is going to be taking the
instrument systems that we've already
invested in
and using those it's going to be taking
and utilizing those newer technologies
like sequencing which allow us very very
high degrees of throughput
at very low costs and being able to use
those types of technologies and expand
the use of those technologies and it's
also about
getting those point of care diagnostics
into the hands of our first line
healthcare providers as quickly as
possible as well so it's really got to
be a multi-tiered approach
that we have to take and if you don't
mind i actually wanted to ask russell a
question
uh based on one of his answers if you
don't mind sure of course
so russell one of the things that's been
kind of interesting that we've seen
in one of my neighbors to the east in
the state of michigan is we've seen a
massive
expansion of cloven 19 in michigan and
michigan has been
very very hard hit throughout the
pandemic now this really seems to be
the b117 variant any thoughts as to why
b117 is having such a dramatic effect
in michigan but we're not seeing it in
indiana
we're not seeing it in illinois or even
really in wisconsin
it's been kind of an interesting
phenomenon do we think that that is
more of a localized patient or you know
more of a localized population issue
or do you think that there's something
special about that variant
uh it's a great question great
observation nate
when i think about the answer i just
look to the data in england because
it was identified
early on in southeast england but when
they finally looked at the data across
the regions they realized it was moving
pretty rapidly across all of england
over the period of like three or four
weeks so
i think you're correct yeah michigan is
is a hot spot right now
but i think next week the week after
we're gonna find it's in
illinois it's in indiana it's in
wisconsin
you know it's already here in
massachusetts uh it is more infectious
you know i've seen different numbers of
infectivity 1.5 or so more than the
wuhan strain
so we really have to you know keep a
close eye on the recommendations by the
cdc for for
masking and you know all of the the good
things we've been doing to keep this
pandemic under control
thank you so much gentlemen now dr
larabar you brought up
regulations and some of the barriers
someone just did a follow-up question
and said how do you plan or maybe all
labs plan to deal with those kinds of
regulatory barriers
so i think number one we've already seen
a shift and i mean the fda really
you know they've gotten a lot of
criticism but they've actually responded
very very nicely they're they're very
very quickly reviewing assays getting
them onto the market
um they have really moved to the idea of
trying to get things sped through
the approval process as well i think one
of the smartest things the fda did
very early on was to say okay if you're
using a modification of the cdc assay
you can fall under the cdc's eua
approval
and you can go with it it's
substantially equivalent um
i yeah but i think at the end of the day
how do we prepare this for the next
pandemic
i think it's really going to come down
to our professional societies whether it
be
the college of american pathologists
whether it be the uh
you know whether it be ascp or the
american society for clinical pathology
aacc amp asm
you know any idsa any of the our
societies or all of our societies
really coming to the fda and saying this
is the framework that we need to build
to respond to the next pandemic
and that's going to have to be a very
collaborative effort
and it's going to have to be done also
in collaboration with the who as well
so i think it's going to be you know a
multi-year conversation in terms of how
do we change that regulatory framework
so that it can be responsive we've
certainly also
seen um some interesting information
coming out of the
inspector general inspector general's
office of the fda
really questioning whether the fda has
the ability to regulate lab developed
tests as we continue that conversation a
bit further
um it will be interesting to hear
you know where we ultimately land on
laboratory developed tests and
depending on where that answer
ultimately comes that may be a very
viable option for labs too going forward
thank you so much and this quest next
question i think is on the minds of
everyone how
quickly is this virus mutating
i think it's always mutating and the
question is
is are there any mutations that will end
up being of high consequence
and um so it remains to be determined
um the just a little more background on
on this virus is that many of these
mutations have come
from you know compromised patients
unfortunately because it seems to
reproduce
effectively in immunocompromised
patients who have extended periods of
activity
so again the more we can do to keep the
virus out of the general population
especially immunocompromised populations
um
the crook will be able to get it in
control nate do you have anything to add
to that
yeah i i would just say i mean if we
look at some of the data on it we're
seeing
about seven new variants the data i
recently saw was about seven new
variants a week
that certainly isn't the frequency of
mutation that's variants that ultimately
survive because we have to remember the
vast majority of these variants that
emerge
ultimately are not favorable variants to
the virus and
ultimately that lineage ultimately dies
off so
it's certainly not as bad as it could be
but it's certainly
you know we are seeing a reasonable
degree of mutation that's occurring
thank you so much we have time for one
more question gentlemen
and we'll kind of continue our
discussion about regulations you clearly
show the importance of
lods what changes or recommendations
would you make to the fda or the euas
or other regulatory bodies to ensure
assay performance
meets the requirements for lods and
patient care
so there's two really important things
that are happening
in this particular case susie first of
all we've seen
the first of we've seen the first couple
of
510k approved tests um bio fire for
example went through and got
510k on their respiratory panel
via the de novo 510k submission route so
we're beginning to see the fda
establish a standard for limited
detection
for these tests and i think
you know these first or these early
adopters or the early movers to go
through the 510k process are really the
pioneers and we're going to be moving
we're going to see a lot of additional
assays move through that traditional fda
review route so i think that will be an
important
gating step we've also seen again as
we've seen more contemporary assays move
through the approval process
there is a bit more standardization in
terms of what would be accepted as the
reference standard
how sensitive that test needs to be and
so we see
ultimately a a bit of a more rigorous
comparison that's occurring
again the key issue with this though is
balancing the speed at which we get
assays onto the market really responding
to that issue of
how do we make sure that we develop and
have adequate capacity that's
present on the market with ensuring that
we have good
accurate and reliable assays that are on
market
so i think it will be really important
and really key
for manufacturers moving forward to make
sure that their assays
are designed to be sensitive that they
will identify
the different variants that emerge and
that the assays are
you know well suited for uh for use in
the field if you will
dr garland dr luttabor i want to thank
you gentlemen for your time today and
for your
important research and your presentation
and before we go
i also want to thank our audience for
joining us today
and for their interesting questions i'd
also like to thank our sponsor
lgc sarahcare for sponsoring today's
webinar
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by our speakers via
the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast
can be viewed on demand for two years
until
april of 2023 laboratory alert you via
email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share
that email with colleagues who may have
missed today's live event
until next time stay safe and stay
healthy everyone take care bye